Keberhasilan algoritma VQE kita sangat
bergantung pada state dan circuit
yang kita pilih untuk memulai.
Aku Victoria Lipinska dan dalam video ini
kita akan menjelajahi pilihan-pilihan
yang kita miliki dalam merancangnya.
Mari kita lihat lebih dekat semua elemen
yang kita punya dalam setiap jalannya bagian
kuantum dari VQE.
Kita mulai dengan reference state,
terkadang disebut initial state.
Kita jalankan reference state
melalui parameterized circuit yang disebut
variational form
dengan pilihan awal parameter,
dan kita ukur state
dalam basis Hamiltonian
setelah menjalankannya melalui circuit
untuk mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi. Sekarang
kita akan membahas masing-masing elemen ini,
dimulai dengan reference state.
Pilihan yang umum untuk reference
state adalah state nol.
Yaitu state di mana komputer kuantum
sudah diinisialisasi.
Untuk masalah kimia kuantum,
seseorang juga bisa menggunakan apa yang disebut
Hartree-Fock State,
yang merupakan hasil dari
metode Hartree-Fock.
Singkatnya, teori Hartree-Fock
memberikan cara sederhana untuk membangun
reference state dengan mengaproksimasi
ground state dari sistem kuantum.
Ini menemukan rotasi
dalam ruang state
yang meminimalkan energi ground state.
Akhirnya, reference state
juga bisa sangat spesifik untuk masalah,
dan kamu mungkin ingin memilih
state yang kustom.
Dalam kasus ketika kamu tahu properti apa yang
dimiliki sistemmu, misalnya simetri
atau jumlah elektron tertentu
dalam state, kamu bisa menggunakannya
untuk mendapatkan konvergensi yang lebih baik dari algoritma
VQE.
Memilih reference state yang baik penting untuk konvergensi
reference state yang dekat dengan
ground state
bisa membuat masalah konvergen
jauh lebih mudah dan cepat.
Sama pentingnya
adalah pilihan nilai parameter awal
yang kita masukkan ke dalam variational form.
Oleh karena itu, tergantung pada reference
state dan parameter awal,
kita mungkin konvergen dengan cepat, lambat
atau tidak konvergen sama sekali.
Mari kita lihat plot ini
dan untuk tujuan visualisasi,
bayangkan ruang parameter kita
hanya memiliki satu parameter.
Reference state yang sangat bagus
bisa memungkinkan kamu memulai sangat dekat
dengan ground state akhir
dan kemudian konvergensi akan cepat.
Di sisi lain, kalau kamu memulai sangat jauh
dari ground state di sini,
reference state
a, kamu harus melewati halangan energi yang tinggi
yang mengarah ke konvergensi yang sangat lambat
atau tidak konvergen sama sekali.
Kita akan membahas ini lebih mendalam
dalam modul optimasi klasik
di kursus ini.
Sekarang mari kita lihat parameter circuit
yang bekerja pada reference state, alias
variational form.
Ketika circuit ini, yakni
U dari theta bekerja pada reference
state,
ini menghasilkan apa yang kita sebut trial state
psi dari theta atau kadang ansatz.
Ansatz state inilah yang kemudian diukur dalam basis yang sesuai
untuk mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi
dari energi.
Variational form
yang kita bahas di sini
WEBVTT
dimotivasi oleh kimia.
Namun, ingat
bahwa ada juga yang terinspirasi
oleh quantum machine learning
dan algoritma jangka pendek lainnya
seperti quantum
approximate optimization algorithms.
Mari kita bahas
beberapa pilihan umum untuk ansatz kimia.
Unitary coupled cluster atau UCC
adalah metode yang awalnya diusulkan
dalam publikasi VQE pertama,
dan umumnya digunakan dalam masalah
kimia kuantum.
Biasanya,
ketika kita memparameterisasi state kuantum,
kita bekerja dengan banyak parameter
secara eksponensial.
Namun, untuk membuat
circuit persiapan yang efisien,
kita butuh jumlah operasi yang polinomial
dan karenanya jumlah parameter
yang polinomial.
UCC adalah contoh cara menyiapkan
trial state dengan circuit seperti itu
dan berasal dari metode coupled cluster,
yang merupakan standar emas dalam kimia
kuantum.
Pilihan yang paling umum adalah unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
ansatz atau singkatnya UCCSD.
Karena UCCSD dimotivasi oleh konfigurasi
elektronik spesifik dari masalah,
kita perlu memastikan kita punya reference
state yang mencerminkan sistem dengan benar.
Ini adalah Hartree-Fock state.
UCCSD ansatz biasanya memberikan
aproksimasi yang baik dari ground state
karena menangkap eksitasi elektron tunggal dan ganda
dalam molekul tertentu.
Jumlah parameter dalam UCCSD berskala
secara kuadratik dengan jumlah
orbital spin.
UCCSD bisa disesuaikan dengan sangat baik
untuk suatu masalah,
tapi sayangnya, skala kuadratik
masih menghasilkan circuit yang sangat dalam
yang sulit untuk komputer kuantum
saat ini.
Itulah kenapa peneliti IBM mengusulkan
pendekatan yang lebih heuristik,
di mana seseorang bisa menyesuaikan variational form
dengan hardware yang mendasarinya
yang menghasilkan circuit yang bisa dieksekusi
secara efisien.
Artinya, trial state diparameterisasi
oleh quantum gate
dan diadaptasi
untuk perangkat fisik yang tersedia.
Ini adalah pendekatan yang sangat heuristik
yang ramah hardware.
Berdasarkan contoh-contoh ini, mari kita lihat
spektrum kemungkinan
yang kita miliki untuk mengekspresikan
variational form kita.
Banyak di antaranya
sudah diimplementasikan dalam Qiskit
jadi aku dorong kamu untuk mencoba sendiri
mana yang paling cocok
untuk masalah yang kamu coba selesaikan.
Kalau kita melihat grafik, di satu sisi
kita punya variational form
yang sangat heuristik.
Ketika spesifisitas masalah rendah, tapi
mereka dirancang untuk diimplementasikan
pada hardware yang nyata.
Mereka juga sangat ekspresif, dalam artian
seseorang bisa mengekspresikan
banyak state kuantum dengan mereka.
Namun,
masalah yang mungkin muncul di tahap
optimasi klasik selanjutnya adalah
menghadapi
yang disebut barren plateau,
yang akan kita bahas di modul berikutnya.
Di sisi lain,
kita punya unitary coupled cluster
yang sangat spesifik untuk masalah, yang bekerja
sangat baik dalam kimia klasik tapi
WEBVTT
sulit diimplementasikan pada hardware kuantum
karena kedalaman circuit yang besar.
Secara umum, perhitungan
bisa lebih berhasil kalau kamu bisa,
pertama-tama pilih reference state
dan set parameter awal
yang membuat ansatz state
dekat dengan ground state.
Dan kedua, hindari parameter yang tidak perlu.
Ini entah memperkenalkan
kedalaman circuit yang lebih besar tanpa hasil
atau menciptakan ruang parameter yang lebih besar
untuk dicari yang mengarah ke plateau
dalam optimasi klasik.
Parameter apa yang diperlukan adalah sebuah pertanyaan
spesifik masalah
yang memerlukan pemikiran yang matang.
Mari kita bicara tentang di mana tamu kehormatan kita,
Hamiltonian, bersembunyi dalam semua ini.
Seperti yang kita pelajari di bagian sebelumnya,
Hamiltonian setelah pemetaan qubit
direpresentasikan sebagai jumlah
string operator Pauli yang berbobot.
Akhirnya, namun,
kita ingin mengevaluasi nilai ekspektasi
dari Hamiltonian kita pada ansatz state
yang dihasilkan oleh variational form.
Untungnya, mekanika kuantum itu bagus dan linear
dan inilah yang akan kita gunakan
untuk mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi.
Begini cara kerjanya.
Kita tahu Hamiltonian adalah jumlah
Pauli yang berbobot
karena linearitas
nilai ekspektasi dari jumlah
sama dengan jumlah nilai ekspektasi
dari setiap string Pauli.
Nah, ini bagus karena seperti yang sudah
kamu tahu, mengukur dalam basis Pauli
semudah rotasi
dari basis pengukuran standar.
Daripada mengukur nilai ekspektasi
pada Hamiltonian besar yang direpresentasikan
sebagai jumlah, kita pertama-tama mengevaluasi nilai ekspektasi
dari suku-suku individual
dan menjumlahkan di akhir
dengan bobot yang sesuai.
Itulah kenapa dalam banyak sumber
kamu akan melihat hanya rotasi qubit tunggal
setelah ansatz.
Inilah yang mengimplementasikan Hamiltonian
dalam setiap eksekusi circuit.
Dalam video berikutnya,
kita akan menjelajahi apa yang terjadi
selama langkah optimasi klasik.
Sampai jumpa di sana.